as you watch this brand new footage of
armored Core 6 I'm curious what do you
see armored Core or Souls
[Music]
truth is there's a bit of both here
honestly I recognize the
three-dimensional combat of armored Core
I've seen its familiar Mission structure
its atmosphere and the unrivaled
customization potential that the mecca
genre lays claim to but finally no one
can deny that there is a lot of souls
influence in this this hard lock-on is
not traditional armored Core the pacing
and the telegraphed attacks would not
look out of place in a Souls game even
the Stagger system is basically Securus
now there's a lot I could say right now
but I'm honestly really tired of this
whole debate and I prefer to move on
because there is now so so much more to
talk about instead so Bandai Namco has
given me about four minutes of gameplay
to share here today but I've actually
seen a lot more than this press we're
actually able to see a live demo of
basically this entire Mission and you
know the best part of that live demo
it's that unlike in this gameplay the
HUD the heads up display was completely
enabled I paid a lot of attention to
that and while I don't have any footage
of it this is roughly what it looks like
feel free to pause here but I will break
down this HUD more in depth later in the
video so that you can understand it all
now I don't know why they haven't just
shown it I think it's actually the most
genius part about the game that I saw
and I can't wait to explain why but
right now though I guess I should just
showcase the gameplay that I have been
given
in this Mission it's our goal to
infiltrate this huge facility it's
occupied by doses who are addicts
basically they're people that have been
using that substance that's called Coral
as a drug but the facility is also
occupied by a group of arms dealers who
have this rad logo and it's their
machines that repel your intrusion as
well in the Showcase from software
emphasized the multiple paths that you
can take within the mission you can sort
of see those upper and lower paths here
off to the left and they lead to a
bridge in the distance but this player's
build at least has very efficient flight
capabilities so they use that to take a
more direct approach
okay
obviously vertical and horizontal flight
is a big thing in this game the energy
consumption during vertical flight in
particular reminded me a lot of the
early generations of armored Core so you
can fly upwards but it's probably near
impossible to achieve sustained vertical
flight which I think is a good thing as
it stops you from flying over what is
clearly More Level design than armored
Core has traditionally had which is
amazing one thing that does seem
different though is it seems like you're
way more energy efficient while flying
and gliding horizontally in this game
which is something that seems to be
partly enabled by The Assault boost
which is basically a Dodge boost that
can be held for more distance and a
continued overboost so to speak
let me just pause here for a second did
you hear that little beep
so we're now in range of those enemies
down there and
see the HUD then you would know that our
lock-on has just automatically jumped
onto the closest one our missiles are
now primed and we're now in what I'm
calling a soft lock-on state in this
state we still have really free
unrestrained unguided movement of our
Mech and it seems the lock-on can be
freely moved between enemies this should
be more familiar to armored Core fans
because it's closer to the way that
lock-on has traditionally worked in
armored Core where you're responsible
for keeping enemies within your sights
in order to shoot at them and the
lock-on kind of does its own thing so if
we fire our missiles now which they do
you can see one missile fly off to each
nearby enemy stunning them and giving us
an opening to dash in and take them out
one by one instead except at some point
the player locked on manually and now
we've transitioned into what I'm going
to call a hard locked on State
now that the enemies are dead hardlock
finally falls off but wait there's more
enemies up top so the player goes up and
commits to more hard locked combat
against them and again in this hard
locked State we see a lock that entirely
dictates the direction you're facing and
that is not how lock-on has
traditionally worked in armored Core in
fact the absence of hard lock-on is I
think actually a big part of what
contributed to armored core's
traditional identity so instead you'll
recognize this lock-on state from Souls
but before all the armored Core fans get
upset by this perhaps rightfully so
remember the genius kind of is that the
soft lock-on State the traditional
lock-on State still seems to exist and I
think playing with that lock-on state
will be viable and it will give you
benefits although you're probably
missing out by not hard locking on
sometimes and allowing the player and
their camera to be very bound to a
single enemy and have your movement
strafe around them perfectly instead
what's more in this hard lock-on State
notice how all four missiles go to their
single Target here instead as opposed to
in the soft lock-on state where those
missiles were spread evenly around the
area to each enemy
that enables some really cool strategy I
think and speaking of strategy this
player's combat strategy seems to be to
use their machine gun to stagger these
smaller enemies enemy stagger bars are
seen here and they build up visually
just like they do in sekuro and you can
see the moment that stagger kicks in
here
in this staggered State they've said
that enemies take a ton more damage and
that makes it the perfect time to hit
them with all your burst damage which
this player does with their barrage of
four missiles
or another thing you can do while the
enemy is staggered is this
you can eat enemies so far with this
kick attack though I feel like this
enemy only flew so far because it was
already staggered though in any other
situation the kick attack probably just
builds up their stagger meter instead
next clip the gate was a major Waypoint
in the Showcase and it seemed to
function a lot like a fog Gatewood in
Souls except when I watched the player
actually took about 10 seconds to hack
Open this gate they were vulnerable the
entire time they were doing that and
they even got ambushed during that
process so it's a cool way to sort of
stop you from progressing too far in
Souls you can just like run past
everything so it's kind of good that
they stop you doing that here but here
they enter a tight Corridor and these in
armored Core traditionally force you to
fight quite differently than you would
have out in the open often in past
armored Core games your missiles would
become useless inside especially if
they're the type that fire upwards or
outwards and your long-range Weaponry
might not be as good either so that's
why it's a good idea to have some close
range parts to help you out in tight
spaces like Shields now or maybe in
melee blades as well
speaking of shields they've actually
added something that I've always wanted
them to add in souls and that's a timed
block system so what we know from
interviews is that Shields now have this
brief moment when you deploy them where
their defense is way stronger it happens
here see that pulse when they pull it
out that should be a moment of optimal
block and that's obviously an incentive
to perfectly time your blocks against
strong attacks rather than just keeping
your Shield active all the time next
melee weapons you can clearly do
multiple strikes with a lot of these and
having these preset animations makes me
think that the blades might be exclusive
to the left side like they are in many
previous armored Core games rather than
being able to dual wield them although I
could definitely be wrong on that next
we see the scan function for the first
time enemies are revealed and can be
locked onto through walls I love this
being able to peek ahead and think about
your strategy is so much better than
always being forced to figure things out
on the fly it enables planning based on
your build followed by execution of that
plan with your reflexes and your
coordination and that is Peak armored
Core to me
speaking of customization though next
let's talk about build assembly in the
garage which is another huge design
pillar of armored Core so here we
thankfully get an overview of all of the
part categories in armored Core 6. here
are your four weapon slots your four
frame slots and then your booster your
FCS lock-on part your generator and an
expansion slot this is fewer categories
than most armored Core fans will be used
to inside Parts Hangar weapons radiators
those are all missing here that said the
parts that we do see previewed here do
have some great depth to them so I think
that might make up for having fewer
categories for example your generator
which governs your energy now has
cooling built into it rather than
radiators being a separate part and then
certain weapons like this laser dagger
can perform a charge attack if held
which is a depth to the Play We also see
certain ranged weapons that have this
charging property as well and then
there's missiles which have unique
attack characteristics you know as they
always have but their descriptions here
are more detailed than ever some are
capable of multi-lock which is when
missiles fire at multiple targets which
I showed off earlier some missiles are
better for AOE creating a damage area
some are better for staggering enemies
like these which contribute greatly to
build up of ACS strain and some missiles
will just be great for taking out
Airborne enemies like these which are
deliberately slowed down missiles Hound
targets during lengthy Airborne time
enabling heavy pressure tactics all
these build considerations are such a
fun amazing part of armored Core that I
can't wait for people to discover and if
you're a new player I think a lot of the
time you will be able to get by simply
reading these written descriptions but
the real endgame game in armored Core is
learning to understand the complex stats
and specs of each part seen down here
though if you think these stats are
overwhelming I've got news for you so
this is probably the simplified version
it reminds me a lot of armored Core 4
where you were shown the most important
stats on Parts but then you could toggle
the display to reveal this
yeah so stats can get pretty intense and
while having a simplified View and
glanceable icons is obviously the more
modern approach I really hope that they
don't shy away from these overwhelming
stat screens because they are such a
Hallmark of the series
in the Showcase the player actually
accessed this garage Mid Mission after
being destroyed by this quad-legged
enemy their mid-range biped build was
having a lot of trouble dealing any kind
of damage to this enemy at range so they
wanted to change their build to an agile
close range one instead and they did it
all manually and it took less than a
minute and it was so convenient instead
of having to do the entire Mission again
they simply died they loaded up the
garage from the menu they tweaked their
build and then they returned to the
checkpoint that they had unlocked in
their mission and they were back with a
different build completely but as to the
fight itself there's actually so much to
break down in this fight but the main
thing I really want to talk about
happens here where they finally stagger
the enemy
whereas insecuro this would enable an
execution on stagger in armored Core 6
it's up to you to fully deliver that
execution the enemy is now taking extra
damage so if you have burst attacks
Now's the Time what's more it seems you
can prolong this staggered state with
certain attacks keeping them stun locked
with the right combo potentially which
might give a really high skill ceiling
to this whole process
if you listen carefully here you can
hear a narrator say all right tourist
that's enough that's because the enemy
leader of this facility has been
talking you this entire time the
dialogue that I heard was witty and well
delivered and that is a very welcome
change from past armored Core games
there was also some banter between this
narrator and your own female operator
who is there to support you through your
missions and warn you about what's ahead
and a main boss is ahead but before this
in the demo the player actually called a
resupply drone replenishing their health
their repair kits and their ammo and
then it was time to fight this thing a
boss that has its own health and stagger
meter that appears at the top of the
screen its attacks are extremely well
animated and telegraphed and it has a
ton of area denial and AOE and it's just
so well animated and it looks like such
a great fight it also has two lock-on
points a weak spot the front and a Chute
at the top which I guess flying builds
might be able to take more advantage of
I wonder how a slow tank build would
deal with something like this though it
seems like it would be hard to get
distance and Dodge with the tank hay
anyway as promised let me recreate the
heads up display in more detail starting
with the most important things first up
is your AP your armor points or your
health basically which was displayed
numerically and with a slider around
here when the player took damage this
number and the slider would obviously
deplete and the screen would also
distort a little bit especially at the
edges which you can kind of see here
then there was the energy gauge seen
around here this was depleted by things
like flight quick boosting and I think
melee as well of course in armored Core
how big this bar is is determined by the
capacity of your generator part and how
fast it depletes and recovers is
determined by the n energy output of
that generator and the cumulative energy
drain of all of your parts
of course the efficiency of your
boosters will probably also play A Part
above it was a stagger bar it was empty
by default but would fill up with orange
from the center just like this whenever
you took damage and then it would
deplete if you didn't take damage for a
few seconds the same goes for enemies if
you get staggered though I think you
just sort of pause for a couple of
seconds and previous interviews seem to
suggest that you'll start falling if
you're in the air as well next there was
like a box here for the expansion slot
so extensions are a category of parts
that have traditionally allowed you to
do unique things like jam enemy radar or
shoot down enemy missiles automatically
sometimes these extensions were
activated manually sometimes they're
passive and they're like my favorite
part category in armored Core because
they give a ton of character to your
build
unfortunately I'm pretty sure the demo
had no expansion pod equipped so this
box was empty next to it were two bars
one was a visual indicator for your
repair kits of which the player had
three armored Core has never had an
Estus flask equivalent before but it
does now these can be activated
instantly to heal the player and it
seems they can be replenished at Supply
stations which can be called in certain
missions apparently underneath repair
was a bar that said scan when activated
to scan surroundings for enemies this
bar would take a little while to
regenerate and then it could just be
used again it wasn't long though like 10
seconds between each scan maybe on the
bottom right were four familiar weapon
slots they showed you a total ammo and
your remaining magazine ammo for your
left arm right arm left back and right
back weapons respectively this character
has missiles on their right back a
machine gun on their right arm a shield
on its left back and a blade on its left
arm now a recent interview stated that
all four weapons are bound by default to
all four controller triggers and that
all of your weapons can be fired at once
which is not how it's worked in any
previous game that sounds kind of insane
honestly and pretend you're holding a
controller I cannot fathom for the life
of me how you're supposed to fire all
four weapons with your pointer and
middle finger and then doesn't that just
leave your thumbs free for assault
boosting and boosting and moving and
interacting and changing weapons
just your thumbs for all those actions
seems very difficult so I'm extremely
Keen to get a hold of a demo and see
what the deal is here there was a
vertical speed gauge on the left there
was what looked like an altitude gauge
on the right there was even a compass at
the bottom that was actually pretty cool
because it had red dots for all of the
enemies around you which I assume would
actually be pretty useful when helping
to locate the enemies that are just
outside your field of view then the
mission objective was written top left a
waypoint marker was on screen for that
objective and killed enemy credit
rewards would pop up on the bot right of
course as mentioned earlier the center
of the screen features Your Fire Control
System your lock on essentially it's
circular like it was an armored Core 5
and while you're out of combat even it
stays in the center of your screen and
it has these sliders that help you keep
track of your remaining magazine
capacity as you fire your left and right
arm and back weapons which I'm a huge
fan of so the UI is nice it's super
clean and it displays a ton of
information but it's this lock-on
behavior that I think is the most
fascinating thing about armored Core 6
so far and this is the part of the UI
that I kind of love the most so again
when you get in range of an enemy this
lock-on element jumps over to them while
the lock-on display itself starts to
display that enemy's health and stagger
meter at the top in addition to your
ammo in the bottom left and right inside
the lock-on though there's this little
number which dictates how many of your
missiles will go to this enemy should
you fire them again if you're soft
locked on that number will be split
between nearby enemies and if you're
hard locked on all of your missiles will
go towards them Additionally the lock-on
actually updates with an enemy's
distance from you which is extremely
important information because staying at
optimal weapon range is a really big
thing in armored Core and it also shows
little damage numbers which pop up as
you pop off and that's really important
to give you visual feedback on the
effectiveness of your range or the
effectiveness of your weapon type you
want to know if you're dealing damage
and I always loved this feature when it
was added in armored Core 4 so I'm very
glad to see that return I even noticed
some little enemy status words pop up
around the lock box like unaware would
pop up if the enemy didn't know you were
stealth and ACS load limit I think pop
popped up if you staggered them so this
lock-on is doing a lot of heavy lifting
in armored Core 6 and I love it I'm glad
they've baked so much information into
this UI because that is such a huge part
of what armored Core is all about and
what their design team deserves props
for is the fact that they've baked all
this information in while keeping
everything looking sleek and unobtrusive
it's very clever design and I hope they
show off the HUD soon because I'm
probably just butchering it in Photoshop
now
I have so much more to say about this
demo but it should probably wait for
when we get new footage or for if I get
my hands on it if I'm lucky in the
meantime if you're curious about armored
call then please check out my recent
video where I show off every single old
armored Core game and I think that video
will just always stand as a way for you
guys to learn a ton about the series if
you don't have the time to play for
yourself and I had an amazing time
playing all of the old games but until
next time thank you for watching I also
want to say special thanks to con from
Bandai Australia for getting up at
midnight to pass me this footage that
was so appreciated and it's honestly
half the reason I had enough time to
edit all of this for you guys so thank
you con and same goes for Steven at
Bandai and countless others who just
enable these kind of demos and previews
behind the scenes thank you and if
you're a content creator who couldn't
get access then you're more than welcome
to react to this video and to this
footage I hope that helps somewhat but
thank you again for watching
I'll see you next time
all right
foreign
[Music]
all right sir that's enough
foreign
question